um
but there's some some stuff which is a
little different so hopefully that'll be
interesting uh that's the stuff that
i'll get to at the end because i felt
like i needed to connect it to adiabatic
quantum optimization as that was the
title that i gave the mage at some point
um
so i have a few thoughts about that at
the end uh what i want to start with
though is to actually just tell you that
what we heard about in the first talk
this morning
or at least the final conclusion uh
is uh completely wrong
that exponential complexity whatever
that means of um quantum mechanics uh
can extend to maybe not high temperature
but high energy density um
okay i'm gonna be vague about exactly
what that means but hopefully it'll be
clear why i say that uh in the intro
part of this talk which is going to be
just sort of uh an intro some
perspective on what many body
localization is from a physics point of
view
and then uh i'll tell you
in the middle of the talk about uh a
really sort of pathological model that
we've been studying as a mean field sort
of analytically tractable approach to
understanding this phenomena of many
body localization um and then i'll make
some comments about how can i say
adiabatic quantum optimization maybe as
i go along and a couple conjectures i
came up with while thinking about it
this week
um so this is work done
uh or the technical part of this is work
done in collaboration with um arijit pal
at harvard
and antonellos
who is at ictp currently on sabbatical
uh in the east coast though
so what's what's the motivation
so it's actually uh fairly fundamental
statistical mechanics uh
the whole
topic
uh relates thermodynamics things that
you can observe in big systems to the to
the microscopic world and the starting
point for deriving the gibbs uh
distribution the boltzmann ensemble is
uh arguments about exchange
that basically systems come to
equilibrium and in order to do that they
have to be able to exchange between a
system and environment all of their
conserved quantities energy
particles things like that
okay
so
what if there is no environment and we
just have a closed quantum system
this is perhaps why my talk is different
from yesterday's talk
where he hit it over and over with
windblad operators so um
well an ergotic system
which i'll define sort of in a moment
for you is a system which behaves as its
own bath so in particular if i imagine
some big physical system which has lots
of interacting degrees of freedom then
there can be
some quantum spins or electrons or
whatever we want to think about usually
in our idealizations but there's also
some environment which is phonons in the
lattice or fluctuations of
other coupled degrees of freedom um and
we usually treat that in sort of this
markov approximation or something
analogous to it that it's thermal
but you could also include everything
put everything into your hamiltonian and
say that you know the universe is
quantum mechanical really it's just
closed system unitary dynamics
so
what does it mean for the system to
behave as its own heat bath well the
idea is that
a quantum system
thermalizes or the notion of
thermalization is that subsystems finite
subsystems of this larger system
will go to thermal equilibrium at long
times
that's what that's how you can define a
notion of thermalization despite having
unitary dynamics for a system as a whole
okay so let me unpack that a little bit
i'm imagining that i have some system
dynamics which are unitary
and i'm only going to consider finite
subsystems i look at those finite
subsystems
at long times starting with any initial
conditions i want
and actually any finite subsystem i want
and
thermalization would imply that
the the limiting behavior of that
subsystem density matrix agrees
with the equilibrium density matrix that
i would calculate at appropriate
temperature chemical potential etc for
the conserved quantities the globally
conserved quantities in the system
okay
so
as i said it this this idea of of of
thermalization ought to be true for all
finite subsystems and all initial
conditions uh consistent with the
conserved quantities and and if it is
true then that's that's a that's
ergodicity in the quantum setting that's
how we can justify
uh quantum statistical mechanics writing
trace e to the minus beta h
as a useful thing to do to calculate
observables
um
so
this leads
to something known as the eigenstate
thermalization hypothesis which is that
uh for a system to equilibrate from all
initial conditions
all many body eigenstates need to agree
with equilibrium on the subsystems
okay so here i have
a
closed system hamiltonian that's the
full hamiltonian full system i have many
body eigenstates e i
and i again look at the reduced density
matrix of a subsystem but in this eigen
state
this is not the ground state actually
there are no ground states in my talk so
don't get confused
okay i'm always at very high energy
and but in these high energy density
states high energy states when i look at
subsystems
in any many body state anybody i can
state i'd expect it to look like
equilibrium if this hypothesis holds
so
uh
as the title of the slide suggests this
is a hypothesis
and
it
i don't believe has been proven in any
particularly interesting models it's
sort of heuristically believed in lots
of cases um
and
uh there's numerics to that have
investigated it in a number of settings
yep so there's just a hamiltonian
so what about simplicity so i understand
that
there is long time and very long time so
that's it
so
so eventually it should return
to where it started so so okay so
technically
i want to think about a very big system
and
let me
so any
the the many body level spacing will get
exponentially narrow in that system size
so any cyclicity is going to go to
exponentially long times
so because you're kind of looking at the
limit
and
some of the time compared to the well so
this statement actually i think you you
don't really need to take a limit you
can just say
do my eigenstates have this property
that they agree
you know with appropriate errors but
that they agree with what i would
estimate from a gibbs ensemble
because this doesn't say anything about
actually the time dynamics if this holds
true then any observables you measure in
a local
a local box
uh
will agree with
uh the equilibrium properties even if i
set up an initial condition i was
thinking about putting putting this
calculation in even if i set up an
initial state which is not an energy
eigenstate of the many-body system it's
some superposition of energy eigenstates
and you might think that there's phases
and all kinds of things as the time
evolves
if this condition holds true it doesn't
matter all local observables will
actually just agree with the equilibrium
at long times
because
well basically the dephasing will just
get pulled out of the expectation values
okay
so
so
actually it's it i can say
thermalization is a hypothesis is i
think it's an interesting one because it
seems to hold in a lot of
uh a lot of settings and it is really
the starting point for claiming that
quantum stat mech is applicable to
long time observe to time average
observables or observables
that we measure in a big system
uh which would be isolated
um
so
a key feature of
do you know it yeah where we know it
holds
for sure or like numerix is fine too but
where yeah so there's uh numerix on
i think uh
so you have to get away from integrable
models so i think
this
okay i didn't double check i think some
of these papers i put at the bottom of
these recent ones
uh
regal at all talent views they study
some 1d chains that aren't integrable
so probably isaac models of longer range
interaction like next neighbor or
something like that these are the
miracles yeah those are numerical
outcomes
sorry what was that it's a 30-site
non-integrable hot composite model
category
okay yeah yeah yeah and it's probably 1d
yeah sure yeah but yes
that's right um
this might be a bit authentic but
what do the boundary conditions around a
look like
or are there any restrictions on them
when you define broadway equilibrium
state only
so
okay i have dropped all kinds of limits
and sort of arguments about how you go
to thermodynamic limits in time but it
doesn't really matter if you define
this row a equilibrium as being
the trace of the gibbs ensemble for the
for the full system
so you take e to the minus beta h
then trace out a then that's what i mean
by row a so what the boundary condition
is i mean that's whatever it is however
whatever a i take that's what i would
define it as i'm not saying try to
define a notion of hamiltonian for a i'm
saying take the hamiltonian for the full
system do the gives ensemble then trace
that shouldn't matter up to boundary
effects but yeah
yeah one might have thought that being
constraints on the side how local you
have to be depending on the
energy excitation
so basically i'm imagining that these
energies that i'm thinking about are at
extensive energies
so the system is this is where i would
think the system has a temperature
okay i'm not at very i'm
away from order one energies
so local observables they should just
agree with the thermal state basically
is the claim
so the thermal state
you imagine
in some way so there's no
it has a scale where you expect the
entanglement to persist in this case
uh
sorry i'm not sure i understood that
question at the very least there's a
thermal correlation
yeah and
that would be in in this i mean this is
this is really what you would calculate
like you know doing quantum statement
this is what you calculate and this is
just saying if you started the system an
initial condition which had an energy
density consistent with that temperature
so it's thinking microcanonically
and it was really in that initial
eigenstate
but then you calculated observables they
would agree with what you would
calculate in the quantum statmec
approach
okay
okay
so
so right so in order for this to the the
the main physical argument here is that
uh
uh
it is somehow that you know everything
will eventually spread through the
system energy entanglement whatever if i
started in some non-trivial initial
condition i clump things up on one side
in order for this to be true uh i need
to have the energy i clump up over on
this part of the system eventually does
make it to the other side of the system
and that's why you can see that it
requires exchange in order for this to
be a possible scenario at the stage
formulation so what if it doesn't happen
that is if there's no exchange
so quantum statistical mechanics breaks
for localized systems it's sort of one
way to think about it if i have a system
where conserved quantities don't
transport then
uh the isolated system dynamics will not
agree so observables i would see in the
isolated system will not forget what
their initial conditions were and they
need not agree with the thermal state
observables at that energy depth
so
uh
airbaltzman tells us calculate using
this
and
uh professor anderson says nope
okay
so
um
so
this is this is this is
i put anderson here because it's
anderson who first proposed the idea of
anderson localization
and he was talking about uh localization
of um
well what's mostly been understood since
then is localization of waves i'll talk
about it a bit more so that would be
energy with particle waves energy waves
non-interactive waves
um
but he also was thinking about this
interacting setting of localization of
energy and so on in a full model
and
uh if it happens then
sort of all of statneck breaks for these
isolated systems
so let me just as a little more
motivation without a lot of
justification but more to whet people's
appetite um point out a few of the uh
exotic consequences of believing that a
system as many uh some hamiltonian
system could be many body localized well
these have sort of been discussed in the
last few years in various works so if
you have a localized hamiltonian system
the
high energy density states which we
normally would describe as being thermal
may actually have quantum topological
symmetry breaking orders which are not
allowed in thermal equilibrium
so for instance the example here is of a
1d isig model if i have a 1d izing model
say a transversalizing model i know it
can order
it can develop long range ferromagnetic
order at t equals zero
but
if i raise the temperature at all
then there will be proliferation of
domain walls in the system it's an
entropic effect and so
the uh correlation function the
magnetization whichever
as matt
doesn't matter ashwin told us about how
to measure long-range order in the last
day or two all the correlation functions
will decay exponentially because of the
proliferation of defects in one
dimension
at finite temperature
but if i have a transverse field-izing
model with sufficient disorder in it
then the claim
is that you can go to a finite energy
density eigenstate and you can actually
find well all that means is that you put
in some finite density of domain walls
in the system that's how you got to that
energy density but the system is
localized and they can't move
and so if i measure
uh connected correlators in that system
i would find that they have uh they have
sort of a random value depending on what
initial state i put the system in
you know because this is frozen so
this correlation would be
minus and this correlation would be
plus so depending on exactly where i
look there's a frozen in correlation but
it doesn't decay
on average at
long distances so there's long-range
connected correlations
uh
and
similar arguments have been made for
freezing of
top lane sort of developing you can call
this something like glass order because
the magnetization pattern is frozen and
it depends on what state you start so
it's a frozen order depending on your
initial conditions similar arguments can
be made for generalizing topological
order in a distorted torque code or
this is
a picture from
the letting go
topological paramagnet
that indeed if you put disorder into
these systems and they many body
localize which is an assumption that you
can make your plausible arguments for
then you can go to finite energy density
states and still have a well-defined
notion of topological order suitable
modifications from the ground state
um
can i ask you a question but you go
onside that i mean
so what property of topological order
you keep i mean we're of course
interested in quantum information say
well
would that be useful as a quantum memory
uh at finite temperature with this order
i mean it's different from having you
know at one state with top one
right so so that's a good question so
the
there's no finite temperature anymore so
it's that i can set up the system in
some
basically the point would be that in in
these i could put in states
under its own dynamics if i have the
torah code and i perturb it so i have a
closed system i protrude a little bit so
that now my
my charges would normally disperse
right so they start moving the defects
start moving
then if they can move through the system
diffuse through the system under its own
dynamics they will screw up whatever
i've encoded in the
topological subspace
but if they're frozen
they don't
okay so now how you actually use that
is delicate but it's it's an idea which
i think actually has come up a few times
in the last few years is that disorder
can somehow stop defects from moving
effectively and therefore stabilize
the topological pressure people have
analyzed the model historically that's
right it's this order of course that's
right so here the idea i mean
it's a little bit it's a little bit
different if i have
if i imagine that i have a classical
bath
still or something that thermalizes the
system even with disorder the disorder
might slow down the diffusion of the
defects
but because it gets hit externally all
the time they keep moving and so finite
temperature again even in the disordered
setting would
decode the system eventually right
detail here whatever you're trying to
protect but if you're just thinking
about the closed quantum dynamics the
disorder can prevent them from screwing
themselves up
um
and also because we're we're here um
uh
so localized i can say so if i have a
many body localized eigenstate at high
energy density
it has been argued that these would have
entanglement entropy obeying an area law
not just mutual information obeying an
area law
and
so it's a much stronger statement if i
look at these many body eigenstates
then
the
entanglement entropy between the
subsystem and the full system will scale
as the
perimeter the boundary of the subsystem
and that should be contrasted with
ergotic eigenstates so if i had a system
that satisfied eigenstate thermalization
then
um
if i tried to do this calculation of of
entangled entropy of the mix well of
exactly this quantity
then
the reduced density matrix
would agree with the thermal reduced
density matrix
and therefore the entangle the entropy
that i would calculate would agree with
the equilibrium entropy
and i would get a volume law
so this is essentially saying that you
can go to high energy density states in
these strongly disordered systems and
still get a lot of features of those
many body eigenstates that look like
ground state properties
and
it should be surprising in some sense
because when i go to high energy density
just remember in a typical system the
spacing between eigenstates is becoming
exponentially narrow
right
not there's no gap
there's not even a quasi gap there's
lots of states
how how relevant do you think that is
physically because the state that has a
if you're at some level and there's
another state with an exponentially
close energy to get there you would have
to do some extremely non-local thing
so
should you know do these things
feel the nearby states do you think i
know that's kind of a vague question but
should we
like the notion of feeling is not so
vague actually okay
um
right so like perturbation theory you
will not see those until a very high
order
that's that's correct and that's
actually where most of the arguments
that this exists perturbative arguments
that many body localization exists come
from okay but um
there is some notion of states feeling
each other which is that the level
statistics of uh many body localized
eigenstates
are poisson
or conjecture to be and it works in
numerics and in a thermal in an ergotic
phase they are they exhibit level
repulsion
so you know your random matrix theory
ideas go through but even though you've
got this exponential density of states
for the hamiltonian so
these things that have poison
distributed these are the eigenvalues of
the reduced density matrix no these are
the eigenvalues of the full many body
hamiltonian okay
oh i see
as opposed and that's that's different
than
we'll see in a minute okay
okay
so
um any examples
of well either of these so nobody's
proved much except numerically about uh
eth um and there's very little known
really rigorously about many body
localized uh hamiltonians either so
um
okay so i put commuting hamiltonians
here because this is a
quantum
information oriented conference uh
commuting hamiltonians have integer
spectra and
nothing moves so there are many they're
sort of localized in a trivial sense in
that there's no notice version of
anything in those systems uh but that's
not really what we want what we want is
a generic hamiltonian where
in principle things could move
energy particles whatever it could move
um
so maybe a way to frame that although i
haven't thought about it until this
minute is you know if i could make
uh take a model and make an arbitrary
small perturbation to it that i would
still have this property of of
localization would be the key as opposed
to that being a singular effect which it
would be in clean commuting models like
clean to our code you'd expect it to be
a singular effect
um so
so the examples from anybody
localization are strongly disordered
models so we have single particle
anderson localization i'll tell you
about in a second then adding
perturbative interactions to single
particle anderson localized starting
points
uh
which is what reinvigorated a lot of the
study of interacting localization some
arguments there a few years ago and then
a bunch of numerical studies of strongly
disordered models mostly in 1d so let me
give you some
flavor of that so what's the simplest
example
of
um
localization well it's actually have
non-interactive particles which are
strongly disordered and we actually just
go back to anderson localization so here
i have a hamiltonian for a system of it
actually doesn't matter very much but
let's say fermions
which can hop that's the first term and
they have some disordered on-site
potential
and
that potential is chosen from some
distribution of width w
um
and
what happens in the sort of simplest
picture of anderson localization is that
turning on this hopping between the
sites
perturbatively
is is trying to delocalize the single
particle wave functions between sites
but this off resonant hopping it's very
weak hopping between very different
levels fails to hybridize the sites at
long distances so basically i have n
single particle levels and
they roughly speaking have both a
location in space and an energy
they're not extended through the system
and
the sort of caricature is that here's
the energies here's the n levels uh this
spectrum is poisson
uh
the level statistics are and um the
typical states will decay exponentially
from some central place where they're
well defined with some localization
length you see that's sort of the the
simple picture of strongly disordered
single particles
um
going back to phil in 1958
um
so this is sort of a trivial example of
many body localization in the sense that
the full many body eigenstates of this
hamiltonian are just
slater determinant states i build them
up by filling these fermions
and
those states
uh
really are just put a particle here put
a particle there put a particle there
put a particle there their energies
again will be poison distributed as many
body energies and um
and if i make cuts in them entanglement
entropy cuts etc i'll see area laws all
the properties i just told you about
hold
but this is because secretly these are
free systems or not so secretly
so
the
uh
much harder step
is to now argue that
if i start with this set of states and
add in interactions very weakly
that uh
that indeed the many body states
which are exponentially dense
uh
fail to fail to significantly hybridize
and and delocalize the system
okay
so now you think of it as a perturbation
problem where the states you're moving
between are the two to the end
occupation states
sort of corners of fox base
and the
interaction is hopping you in the slater
determinant space
and so there's two to the end states and
they're very dense
so there's no way that your small
v
perturbation is ever actually smaller
than the spacing between
the levels but as you said maybe it
doesn't matter and it's okay
and that's the argument that
bosco laner and obscular in 2006
uh put together
sort of a really big perturbative work
to argue that indeed there's a finite
range of of perturbation v in which the
expansion for particular eigenstates
starting from there converges and that
argues that those states remain
localized all their properties remain
like the single particularly localized
limit
so this is some analytic work you're
saying
it's yes
it's analytic perturbative work
but it throws out i mean it's it throws
out lots of things it's very complicated
perturbation theory
um
and
i don't think you would say it was
rigorous but it is analytic and detailed
so maybe
i don't even think you would say it was
exact actually so sometimes you say
things are uh exact but not rigorous i
don't think you would even say these
things are gap right you start with a
gapped system though because you use
particles or load glock lines
uh but i'm not starting with the ground
state
okay
so i'm starting
so here's say yeah say that there's
almost i don't know say that there's a
gap
so here's my gap here's my ground state
here's my gap
i'm working way up here
where the typical level spacing is e to
the minus n times whatever the entropy
is up here
there's really no gap if you just think
about the many body levels
so but it was this argument due to bosco
internal chiller which actually
got a bunch of people interested in i
think originally trying to show they
were wrong
that this couldn't happen
that
high energy density eigenstates could
not remain localized would be turned on
interactions
and
eventually sort of deciding by studying
a bunch of exact diagonalization in
small 1b models mostly that actually it
could happen
and you could have sorry
if you're saying you just have many
particles right i don't know what you
mean by the ground state there it's not
it's not the vacuum
so yeah so say that i have
i don't know those are my single
particle levels
and then i fill some of them maybe i put
some number
yes right
that corresponds to one of two end
states over here right sure yeah okay so
and then the the gap is to determine you
know get one wall out and then add one
lecture
why you're not fixing the part
i can fix the particle number i will
still have exponentially many states
if i if i say how many states in this
picture which is basically
you could actually maybe this is useful
so say that i look at it as these uh i
shouldn't change location these energies
and alpha right and these are some
random quantities so now i ask the
question of which there are n
right
these are all order one random
quantities so now i ask the question how
many states
so there's some ground state how many
states are there which are consistent in
some little energy window which is
extensive
of order
whose middle is order
energy and that's going to be lots of
different things lots and lots of
different states which correspond to
different fillings
okay
so
i would say these are
it's
in numerix it's becoming increasingly
clear that many body localized systems
may exist
um these perturbative arguments are
there
um in short-range models what we
actually were motivated by
uh
was to come up with some more detailed
theory that you could do something with
in a model a little more analytically
um which is to come up with a mean field
model for
the localization transition so say you
could tune some parameter or some v
and at some point you should have a a
transition from localized to delocalized
and we wanted to have some more uh
control of that so we did something we
decided to look at something which
actually i think i got to know the model
because of a quantum complexity type
conference a few years ago at ictp where
it came up in the context of adiabatic
quantum computing so
um
so i'll show you in a second why um so
this was this is sort of the technical
goal which is that we wanted to find a
mean field model for the many body
localization transition and to be able
to study the wave functions in that
model and so on um
to be able to see whether there are
this is sort of a technical point finite
energy density mobility edges so you
could imagine that in this hamiltonian
as i change my energy at low energies
maybe it's localized and then above some
energy density of the states become
delocalized and i can thermalization
holds it's very hard to show that in any
uh particular model though it's believed
to happen
um
and then localization is sort of
so here's some motivation again from
optimization it's kind of the ultimate
glass everything is frozen
right everything is localized and so is
there any connection i don't know that's
a little bit big so the model that we
decided to look at and which turned out
to be kind of useful
is the quantum random energy model which
some of you who've
attended talks arguing about whether
adiabatic quantum computing works might
recognize
but let me present it this way this is a
model that actually comes from
spin glass theory
and it's the simplest spin glass
is what it's often referred to because
it's built out of what's called the
classical random energy model
where
i take
two to the n states and i just give each
of them a completely random energy so
it's an unstructured energy function if
you want
and
for those of you who know spin class
theory this is sort of a an interactive
body generalization of the shankton
kirkpatrick model but it's
a completely non-local model so this
question of localization in it is a
little bit fishy
but that's something we gave up a little
bit because we were looking for
lean field sort of analytic tractability
we're hoping to capture some some
physics that might show up in in real
localization transitions
um
and what i do is i take this classical
random energy function on
n
diagonal bits or spins
and i just apply transverse field to it
and this is what provides the quantum
dynamics
and it's useful
so you can think of this as being
n qubits in a transverse field with some
energy function it's also useful to
visualize uh the hypercube which where
the corners of the hypercube are just
the z configurations and this transverse
field is really just a hopping term on
this hypercube so this model is very
much like anderson localization on the
n-dimensional hypercube single particle
anderson localization on the
n-dimensional hypercube but it has an
interpretation
in terms of
and spins
um
okay so
now i wanna uh how much time do i have
about 10 minutes
oh okay so let me
take you very quickly through some of
the features of the model
so
the classical limit when you turn off
the transverse field
it's called the simplest spin glass
because it exhibits maybe let's ignore
how it's very easy to solve but let's
ignore it for a second
it exhibits two phases if you just
calculate e to the minus beta h and ask
what does the free energy do so this is
statistical mechanics
there's a high temperature phase which
is a paramagnet and then there's some
critical temperature below which um it
freezes that is the the measure
condenses just the statistical measure
on the state's condenses onto basically
a single state
um and that's why it's sort of a simple
model for this
random this is
viewed as sort of the random replica
symmetry breaking class transition
random first order transition
um
the
quantum random energy model
actually the statistical mechanics so
this is solving
uh
for
what the
phases of this measure look like as you
vary temperature and transverse fields
uh actually was solved this model turns
out to have an exact
exact but not rigorous solution uh by
what's known as the replica trick in an
imaginary time representation um with
certain onsets for um order parameters
let me skip over that
so what you get is actually a phase
diagram which isn't so hard to
understand so the point is that
this is the ground state down here this
is low temperature that's high
temperature
large transverse field small transverse
fields at high transverse field you
expect that the transverse field
dominates and the the spins all just
point along the transverse field that's
your quantum paramagnetic phase
um at low transverse field you get that
classical phase diagram that i showed
you a second ago where in the ground the
low temperatures it's frozen and at high
temperatures there's a classical
paramagnet and these blue lines are
first order transitions in that
thermodynamic phase diagram
um
what is actually missing in this phase
diagram is any notion of what the actual
dynamics induced by h are this is just
evaluating the properties of this
measure
okay
and so if you
take a sort of closed quantum system
point of view a little more rigorously
what you find is that there is a
localization transition so
on
this side
of this
curve so the blue region
the system
is uh ergotic
and so even if you have the closed
hamiltonian with no external temperature
source you would say that uh
statistical mechanics is is a reasonable
thing to look at for long time
observables and
these phases this quantum paramagnet and
this classical paramagnet and this first
order transition between them actually
you know exist
as thermal phases in the closed dynamics
on the other side of this curve the
system is localized
and
uh
which actually tells you that if you
just take the hamiltonian of the system
seriously um
this
isn't meaningful
right i can't that transition is inside
of a localized regime i can't freeze
there anyway because i can't i can't
cool into it i can't do anything if i
really try to reduce the energy of the
system into this regime of the phase
diagram the system gets completely
frozen or it's hard to say how you
reduce the energy when you are imagining
it as being a closed system but if you
started in a configuration which is
consistent with that energy
then it would be completely frozen
observables would not agree with thermal
observables and this transition goes
right through what in the statmet
analysis of this measure
is just a boring high temperature
paramagnetic phase where all the
observables all the magnetizations are
zero basically
due to thermal fluctuations
so
what do i mean by that let me
jump ahead to local observables because
i think this might be clear a little bit
what i'm saying
um
uh
as i said in the in ergotic phase i
expect the local observables to agree
with those of the thermal ensemble the
thermal equilibrium ensemble and so if i
look for instance at the magnetization
of a spin
in an eigenstate
it should be basically the magnetization
that i would calculate at that energy
density for the thermal for a canonical
average okay that's what equilibration
means which means that if i
uh look at the derivative of that
magnetization with respect to you know
finite difference derivative eigenstate
to eigenstate
this
uh magnetization derivative should be
very small should be exponentially small
because the energy spacing is
exponentially smaller
uh whereas in the mini body localized
phase this difference would be order one
because these states really have nothing
to do with each other
and
in this quantum random energy model
there's a subtlety which is that like i
said it's a little bit pathological
because this energy function is very not
local
but if you look at commutators
you can see that basically
the sigma z magnetizations
sigma z operators behave at least they
only change energies by order one and so
you can interpret them as being the
appropriate local observables
and what you see
if you
look at exactly the quantity i just told
you which is the derivative of the
discrete derivative across the entire
spectrum so you are just looking at the
eigenstates and though that observable
and then you get that dynamical phase
diagram
well that's not how i calculated it i
just wanted to give you a picture of it
yeah but yeah yeah but i mean that's the
criterion where you
where you call something you can take
that yes
right that's right
yeah so so numerically i can take any
number of criteria
and they all agree and this is one of
them right analytically we try to
escalate where
we have an analytic analysis we have a
partial analytic analysis yeah which
i'll hopefully be able to flash through
a little bit
um but i just wanted to give intuition
about what it means so
this is the largest system size these
are what i call spider diagrams they're
basically just histograms so if you take
a vertical cut like this that's a
histogram of the value of the derivative
of the magnetization the delta
derivative and magnetization from one
many body eigenstate to the next
histogramed in little energy windows
which is the energy center of those
windows
is down here so at low energy densities
you see that it's strongly peaked
around three values which is basically
that the magnetization can be plus or
minus one so the three values are plus
two zero and minus two
um whereas in intermediate regimes at
high energy or
infinite temperature or high temperature
if you work in a defined temperature you
actually get that this uh is basically
zero that all these derivatives get
tight
um you can actually
the fact that this has width and these
looks narrower uh that's controlled by
the finite sides and you can you can
estimate the list you should look like
this and that one looks like that but
um
let me not go into it too much so
basically the idea is that these high so
the ground state is over here this is
the lowest energy at high energy
densities
i have a system whose eigenstates look
thermal
or whose magnetizations agree with the
thermal magnetization of zero and at low
energy densities roughly below this
point
i have a whole range
of phase where the classical
thermal analysis would tell you this
magnetization should be zero because i'm
in that paramagnetic regime but
this tells you that any chinese state is
actually just frozen
okay
the right hand side is just fine
the right hand side
what over here
uh this would be
this is essentially negative temperature
this is very high energy density
yeah
um
okay so the
uh
uh
what should i talk about so let me tell
you where some of the analytics can go
so the
the simplest
are not the simplest okay so how do we
try to calculate something about this so
we just look perturbatively starting at
the
uh gamma equals zero limit
and we start with the many body wave
function which is just some corner of
this hypercube right and then the
leading perturbative wave function
is going to be f for if i now perturb
with gamma and i ask what's the
amplitude of the wave function at some
other vertex of the hypercube the
leading perturbative wave function is
going to be the sum over paths that go
from my starting point to that
point on the hypercube of
gamma divided by an energy denominator
the intermediate state
and
i
have written forward scattering here
because the approximation we make
which seems to work pretty well is just
to ignore longer loops so whatever the
first order and perturbation theory is
so the shortest path
you just don't worry about anything
after that point
so that defines my wave functions that
i'm going to actually be able to analyze
and
uh
this
we can take as a criterion for
localization that the amplitudes that i
estimate in this approach
decay out to the system size
if they start growing the perturbation
theory is clearly broken it indicates
physically what that indicates is that
there's resonance that's happening and
so if they grow at some distance which
is inside the system then i expect that
the resonances will proliferate through
the system and that corresponds to my
delocalization
um so this has a
sort of physical this pic this
this expression has a nice
interpretation of thinking of directed
random polymers on the hypercube so i
basically fix the end of a polymer where
i want to start i fix where i wanted to
go and then i have some statistical
average of all the possible routes it
can take
with weights
and
there's a
a couple of different things you can do
having made that identification but let
me just take you through a couple simple
heuristics that get you a lot of the way
there so
if i imagine starting an a state whose
energy is extensively away from
infinite temperature which is in zero
energy
right
then
the gap in this
then the states the vertices of the
hypercube that i moved through
um in these paths uh are essentially
independently sampled random energies
from my original energy function
and
those independently sampled random
energies are going to be essentially
sampled from the infinite temperature
uh region regime of the classical model
which means that they essentially are
zero with root n fluctuations
and this energy i started with is order
n
which means that this gap
in the denominator is typically of order
n which is very big
so it has a long tail but it's a
you can control it let's ignore it for
now so let's just sort of naively go
ahead and expand this expression notice
that
assuming that this is much bigger than
that
and then
take an average
okay really what i'm doing is taking the
typical value for this expression and
what you find is that the typical
amplitude at a distance n uh grows as n
factorial that's the number of paths on
the hypercube
times this gamma over
initial energy to the m
and so if we demand notice that as n
gets very big this will always grow the
n factorial will always eventually win
but if we demand that it decays
until at least the system size you
actually predict you you get a gamma
critical which is the energy density um
of this initial state
okay and that's exactly what i that
agrees
that agrees basically with the numerics
up to finance as questions i'll show you
in a second and it's what i plotted on
the
on the curve on that dynamical phase
diagram is that gamma critical line
so this argument
uh needs quite a bit more care if you
start with a state which is already at
infinite temperature so state of energy
zero or roughly zero
because this denominator is now not
small or not big sorry
so for those central energies
you can do a few rigorous things and you
can do some not so rigorous thing that
i'll do on the next slide um but you can
get a feeling for it which is just
we can bound this amplitude to go to
some distance and
by just are not quite bound but we can
estimate it by just estimating what's
the greediest path on this hypercube
that goes to distance n
and essentially
you have capital m choices for the first
step you have n minus one places to the
next step etc and eventually you will
find some
scaling for the greedy path which goes
uh like this the amplitude for this sort
of radius path and this
distance n
and that again if we make the same
demand that this path doesn't cause
the amplitude to become large
gives an upper bound on delocalization
threshold which goes as one over root n
the system size when you're working near
infinite temperature
counting these resonances more carefully
gives a lot of correction
it's even a rigorous log correction but
you can also actually
i'm hesitant to even discuss this
because it's going to make the
mathematically rigorous people here want
to run out of the room and beat me up or
something but you can also actually
solve
this problem using this classic replica
trick so i have random polymers i want
to know what their typical
the distribution of the typical
amplitude is at a given distance and
that means i want to know what the
expectation value of the log of the
amplitude is
and
roughly speaking i can calculate that by
taking this replica limit i imagine
replicating the system n times disorder
averaging that n copies of the system
which means taking a moment
subtracting one dividing by n and then
taking into zero
which means that i didn't replicate the
system at all
but it works so if you uh if you do this
and take it at face value what you have
to evaluate this moment is the
statistical model of n polymers that are
interacting
and you can actually
take a one-step replica symmetry
breaking ons thoughts for it you get
some free energies i will explain it to
anybody who's interested there's a
recipe you follow it's sort of
completely concrete and what's beautiful
about it is at the end
you get that
uh gamma critical is this
okay it just calculates it this is the
answer
all right
in leading one over log out corrections
and you can get higher order
log log corrections and so on just from
doing the algebra
okay and
how does it work
well
so this is something this is
the numerical phase diagram my energy is
on the left axis gamma is here this
gamma equals the critical transition is
the heavy blue line that i've drawn here
so this region here is supposed to be
delocalized the regions over here are
the localized regions
these
contours you see here are from four
different system sizes these are
contours of level statistics actually
but i didn't explain that so it's okay
and those four x's
are what that formula gives you there's
no fit
so basically the finite the idea is that
this boundary which you see in these
four colors as system size gets bigger
this is finite size numerics should
sharpen into this triangle that's what
we believe
and
they actually are pretty good out here
but near infinite temperature the
sharpening is going as one over root n
log n
and you can just plug in this explicit
formula with root pies and stuff like
that and just say okay at n equals eight
that's what that formula says
and it basically agrees with what we see
america
um
which actually i found kind of magical
when we did it but
um
okay so
uh i think
i'm basically done i spent more time
talking in the beginning about
eigenstate thermalization than i planned
but i do want to say one thing about
adiabatic quantum optimization so since
it was in my title um
so um
uh
the random energy model
has been studied in the context of
organic quantum computing as an
unstructured search problem i have
completely unstructured energies on
the hypercube and i want to find the
ground state i can imagine taking my
transverse field and slowly turning it
off and it's an adiabatic computation of
this
ground state and um
it's been studied in a couple of
contexts argued for various reasons to
have an exponentially small gap
so
this is the dictionary annealing the
transverse field is like searching for
the ground state so now the thing is you
know you're going to fail because this
is just unstructured search
so you can even come up with complexity
theoretic lower bounds or information
theoretic lower bounds that you have to
fail if you go faster than exponentially
slowly
uh but you can ask the question what is
the final energy density that you get to
when you do go a little bit faster
you can think of that as an approximate
search for the ground state
okay
um
so then you can ask the question well
what's the scaling of the final energy
density with time and that is related to
how hard is it to approximate
now this is still unstructured search so
i can give you lower bounds which i
hope are correct but i think they are
basically i would expect that
i know it will take exponential time
to find the ground state should go is 2
to the n
okay
that's here so what i plotted here is
the log time divided by n so this is a
rate for my exponential of the time
and the curve is supposed to be the
final energy that i would find the final
energy density that i would find as a
function of that sweep rate
okay so
i will get to the ground state if i go
exponentially slowly okay um
there are three conjectures for what
this function would look like and one
can
now i believe it is an open challenge to
actually calculate it in this
unstructured problem i think it'd be
kind of neat to do and i don't know
there's only one calculation of a curve
that looks like this in the literature
that i could find and it's for a mean
field ferromagnet so it's kind of
trivial
but
simplest conjecture is that if you scale
this rate function so if your time goes
less than 2 to the n but still
exponentially slowly uh you just hit a
brick wall
you you either get the ground state or
you get an infinite temperature state so
zero energy density at the end
right
uh you can take a lower bound which is
essentially just an information
theoretic bound from saying that the
number of states with a given energy
density down here
as a fraction of the total number of
states is given by some appropriate
entropy which you can calculate in this
model and then say well so now i have a
lower bound if i think of it as an
approximation problem that i will find
one of those marked
states and that gives you either this
curve
or
if you allow yourself a grover speed up
a quantum speed up this curve
okay i don't know the answer i tried to
run some numerics just for like
yesterday or something
but the sizes are way too small to get
anywhere near this regime so whatever um
anyway that was that was uh
there's a connection to adiabatic
quantum optimization to throw out to
you know
the aficionados
anyway okay so
uh here's my summary uh
the quantum random energy model provides
a mean field model of the transition
at finite energy density that's
up here
uh
we think we can just
we can discuss exactly what it means
it's a first order dynamical transition
that is not reflected in the
thermodynamic measure at all
you can do a preservative treatment in
this forward approximation
and
do some more rigorous things than what i
showed you also this replica thing seems
to give you the right answer so it gives
you some ability to calculate stuff
about this transition in this model
it's inside what's normally called the
paramagnetic classical paramagnetic
phase of of this model as a spin glass
it's roughly saying
the statmec people spin glass people who
treat this as a beautiful model for lo
for the random big glass transition
as usual have not quite connected the
thermodynamics to the dynamics and it
matters
um
and then there's a sort of funny feature
of this slow approach to the
thermodynamic limit near infinite
temperature um
right so i think i mentioned most of
these questions as i went so
thank you